سلسله غارات شنتها القوات الاسرائيليه على
الاراضي السوريه ردا على اطلاق قذائف
صاروخيه باتجاه هضبه الجولان المحتله
بينها عده مواقع عسكريه في محيط دمشق
والقنيطره شملت مجمعا عسكريا تابعا للفرقه
الرابعه دون انباء عن اصابات المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي اكد ان طائراتهم استهدفت
منظومات رادارات فضلا عن موقع لجماعات
مواليه لايران في محيط قريه ابو قاوق
وبلده السعسع بريف دمشق الجنوبي
الاستهدافات شملت كذلك مواقع مدفعيه لقوات
النظام وجماعات ايرانيه بمحيط قريه الكوم
وساريه الصيد الجولان في محافظه القنيطره
وسريه عابدين وسريه معربه الواقعه بحوض
اليرموك بريف درعا ياتي ذلك عقب اطلاق
ثلاث قذائف صاروخيه من سوريا نحو هضبه
الجولان المحتله اثنتان منها وقعتا في
منطقه مفتوحه وقذيفه اخرى اعترضت من
الدفاعات الجويه كما سبق ذلك اطلاق اكثر
من 30 صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
اسرائيل لم تتبنها اي جهه لكن الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انها نيران فلسطينيه لا
تقفوا ميليشيا حزب الله وراءها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات